ugh
[Music]
oh yeah hi yeah
it's really good to be here yes
nadeem and i had a lot of profound
ascension together
at the shift into permanent alignment
retreat in costa rica
with bentino massaro and the team
and the other attendees
it's like the sun
right that childlike laughter of the
infinite
is like the sun the radiance
the love light warmth
we were seeking ourselves the whole time
yet by doing these
gym repetitions of abiding
in being aware of awareness and being
aware of oneself as
the one infinite creator that
then this sachin ananda becomes more
and more present
[Music]
yes
the last couple of days after the
retreat since
more and more for longer periods and
just in not knowing and it feels so good
every time that there is this i have to
know
something uh i am someone knowing
something
there is this edginess
it's like fate
and innocence and receptivity and
openness sends wonder and
mystery and
i mean these days deeper
thinking in the singularity of what is
and yeah natural fate of that
singularity
yeah yes perfect
[Music]
yet also
there's the beauty in what you just
communicated which is the absolute
absence of symbolization
which is you having arrived at the
destination
and yet there are still so many
that are in the 3d matrix
that are confused and seeking
and they need
the symbolization they need the maps
as adi shankara said 1300 years ago i am
in my village but i need a road to my
village
and so that's the funny cosmic joke
as rumi said too you go from room to
room looking for the diamond that's
already around your neck
and so when you reach the destination
you're just like as you described a
moment ago
yet when you're quote on this
pathless path
that the symbolization the maps
the little waypoints the pins
the retreats the aphorisms the books the
entheogens
all of that stuff compounds
on a conceptual lattice work
that then creates the direct experience
of being aware of awareness
of being aware of oneself as the creator
yeah and it's it's also really true
deeper meditations or deeper
penetrations like the nebulity
i was seeing i'm not this
i'm not that i'm aware of this therefore
it can never be me
if not this then what is i and
it's through this repetition like you
call it that
when you then rest in not knowing it's
vibrant and alive
say that part again you you cut out for
just a moment
that when you when you rest in
specifically the
the mystery and the not knowing
yeah when when when we're resting or
when i write
not knowing in this mystery
uh kind of after uh the application of
will
over and over of seeking myself as the
creator and
seeing through all the layers seeing
throughout the identity structures again
and again
something comes up seeing it in infinite
acceptance seeing
it's not me and then the resting in
fate is so much more uh i would almost
say alive
or vibrant or pristine so there is
definitely relevance like
first application because before
like uh the not knowing is more
conceptually
like you say i don't know and then you
go on knowing things
you think you don't know but yeah just
give up the power of
that you also know what you need to know
when you need to know it
you just gave that up kind of
through that nonchalant or concept
conceptual not knowing
and this in not knowing also gives rise
to communication despite
spontaneous action it's not like
space of uh
non-opening or non-communication with
the play
it's just that it's seen as a uh as a
non-happening and happening
simultaneously
so so yeah
[Music]
ah there's this
restful timeless ease
perfection ineffability of what you
describe
and yet then there's this also this
knowing that the ascensionary process
that we're experiencing in this dream
creation is very clearly
moving from a third density humans
to a fourth density of love having the
the opening of the heart chakra the
green
going from that yellow to green yes
and so then we are the architects
of the transition
into the service to others
into the purity of god's love light
yeah it's like something how even more
clear during the retreat was
how the identity can only care about
itself
the sense of i can only care about the
sense of i
can happen is this i starting to include
all of itself and then there is a
natural response to the
calling or the yeah the calling that
state
uh from the rest of calling upon
some inspiration some information
some pointer some compassion
and all of this and then we can
get the response to each other's value
yeah i love how you put
that this the i
that initially feels like
it's a separate entity
realizes that the i
is shared that the i is impersonal
that the i is eternal and when it does
that process of expanding that's when it
moves from that
third density yellow to the fourth
density love
green that as it does that
that it recognizes that
the best thing for me to do
with this god's love-like calling
is to be shifted into permanent
alignment
in service to others
because it is the same i the same i
am the same awareness that's impersonal
shared eternal yes
yeah and and i think powerful
[Music]
it's kind of like you you see through
the veil
experientially and the eye is now
including
all and then it falls asleep or the body
mind falls asleep again and
again believes it is only the body
only the uh the sense
nadine the personality out of this so
there is a quite a
very uh um
[Music]
different aspect about um
around the dynamics of when you
start your attention
your beingness past service to the rest
of yourself
or to others because in the beginning
it's still
mixed with uh with all the
identity needs right
the okay now i'm going to be of service
and then
i will be more the one infinite creator
or something you know this is also
how it's observed like somehow it it
validates that i'm all the one
creator oh uh i need to make a living
out of
you know i have to survive so there is
the money i speak too and then
how do you be able to stay true to that
well you also want to
make money through what you truly love
to what you are
guided to to explore
there is this uh normalness on
naturalness
in it first i think to be mixed somehow
or very often it is
a natural part of it because here that
progress
to for it to be mixed and then through
the
to the service and and the dynamic there
is a learning that happens and a
purification
and a deepening and letting go of the
needs
the identification with that lower
desires
based in black and within fear
out of this and um
and it's kind of just true of
the
uh stuff all these kinds of things
and i think this is a very powerful
practical
part
through the part of service
and that's far more genuine
and just be honest you know because it's
easy to feel
things within ourselves if we desire
that
if we want to see them it's easy right
you feel it
it's different
so yeah i think this could be a
practical
point you can
yeah hit the tennis ball
back
oh that was so well articulated yeah
ah it's as though when we shift from
that yellow third density to that green
unlocking heart chakra love fourth
density
that as we do that process that
there's not a binary shift done
it's very mixed very very
mixed frequencies so they're still
as you unlock this cosmic consciousness
you unlock this higher state of
love
and you recognize that shared i
awareness being impersonal and
having this desire of true service to
others
that it doesn't start absolutely pure
right off the bat that there's this
mixed
there's this mixness still with the
conditioning
with the psychology with the identity
with the
form with the ego
there's still the mixedness and
over time we gently and sometimes
aggressively separate ourselves from
that psychology from that conditioning
from that yellow
matrixy third density human
algorithmically
scripted limbic
primal
behaviors and patterns more and more
towards
what feels like god's love light
truly purely in service and
that is beautiful to recognize that over
time the frequencies
become more and more clearly separated
i don't yeah
one of the greatest powers is really the
acceptance of
being of the mixedness of the vibration
because it's also
the most difficult in a sense uh
oh just it is the most difficult
because it's the self image we have to
overcome
it's uh hitchhiker like
like before
and every time that we line up our
seeing
with the already accepted nature of all
things
including the program you're running
for now the more that there's this
natural relaxedness
this surround and surrender also just
happens and there is no good reason not
to surrender
when all the reasons we had to surrender
to to identify with the defense
mechanism
have run out are nonsensical then it's
just a
better thing that happens right
when surrendering happens you see that
the moments you are accepting were
already accepted
and the moments not accepting were also
already accepted
and there is just so much
freedom in that because in the moment
when
this this is triggered the
stuff image the eagle
in that moment it is shaky in your
theory field or just in the field you
know it's like
there's this little your heart is
bumping a little bit faster and
then it's that's the moment to make the
choice you know like
okay who am i am i dead
or am i i that's what sees that what
knows that what is free
right and it is in this moment that the
most of
my my power of free will was regained
through seeing no i am not this and then
making the choice based on that seeing
kind of as a
as a result of that choice but also a
verification
of that you know when you see that the
behavior shift
it is the verification that the choice
is made
they're kind of like basing your choices
out of what is the most powerful
for you what is the most regaining of
the free will
it's so potent it's so enlightening
it really allows you to have the true
validation of self
you know like that i exist as freedom
and i can choose i am infinitely
powerful
and if anything all the power is there
that same moment of the already
acceptedness being
recognized
being aligned with
i love your focus there on
acceptance of
the most coolest
aspect to this creation in many ways
as is said in the law of one
and by many of the mystic traditions as
well
is that this reality
is designed by us and has
been iterated on refined
over time to make this
very specific
ascensionary place of that
third to fourth density shift very
exciting very cool very
fun very challenging
very mixed frequency and that's why
accepting
radical acceptance of that cool mixed
frequencies
and also the radical acceptance of okay
there's gonna be conditioning
there's gonna be psychology as i
liberate myself
into more of this heart chakra love
god's love light
vibration that there's gonna be these
little egoic hitchhiker impurities
and then i'm gonna radically accept that
that's the case
and then i'm gonna radically call myself
a fraud
because i'm watching my i'm watching my
frames
when you're really good at watching your
frames
you're good at watching your behaviors
and your patterns
then you can call yourself out on your
bs and you no longer have
the trigger because the trigger
when somebody reflects hey there might
be
some impurity there there might be
some service to self that's happening
disguise that
service to other that you have no
trigger you actually instead what you do
is you say
thank you so much for bringing that up
please let's play with that more please
share with me more that reflection
and then that's also balanced later once
you have done a lot of purity
that then you may get a reflection
that actually is reflecting to you to be
more confident
and so there's also that which is
interesting
that you might get a
more matrix level
reflection from a
third density yellow
mind body spirit complex and you'll have
to
wisely use that fifth density wisdom
balance
to gracefully
decline the reflection that it's
perfect and true but that what's
the lesson coming up is for me to
gracefully decline
and so then there's that also which is
very fascinating and takes
takes a little bit of gym repetitions as
well to get really
subtle at even that
yeah i really love chad because this um
this positive relationship towards
bs
is and
i've eaten deep already so much
um there is always space for deepening
in that in my experience at least um
but it is very crucial you know we
cannot really go deeper if we not
want to see it if we not see that it's
actually a good thing
like you shared every time we go through
it there is a deeper
confidence that arises out of the
clarity because we now saw something
that was out of alignment that was
limiting us
because we we believed in it we chose
with our power of belief and
identification
to give our power to that construct now
we become aware of that constricts a
little bit shaky
but then we can allow this energy to
come back kind of like this free
this frozen free will uh defrosting
again
and so yeah the having a positive way of
seeing that
uh relationship to art seeing this
is very crucial i loved it
yes yeah and i like how you
continue to use this analogy
which is really powerful which is that
in many ways it's as though
the will and the choice is
in a big block of ice and bentino was
sharing this with us at the retreat as
well
this big block of ice that's very
contracted and very separate
and as we've mentioned throughout our
conversation
is that as the block of ice
becomes more and more aware of awareness
becomes more and more aware of love
and the green heart chakra fourth
density love
that it melts it melts more and more
by accepting that it has will and
choice with polarizing itself
towards service to others towards god's
love light
and it gains spiritual mass as
continuous talked about in the mirror
talks
podcast as well gains the polarity of
that spiritual mass as it liberates
itself out of the ice more and more
towards that
god's love light more water more like
liquid
and then eventually
steam vapor
unity
mirror true god's love light the one
infinite creator completely
pure just
blissfully joyfully peacefully
channeling the absolute highest
effortlessly as that steam as that vapor
i love i love being here very much
it's like uh meditation and
communication and some
things yeah
like it
nadine before we started talking when i
asked him i was like
we were just giggling for the first
minute on video chat and i was like
can i send you a stream yard link and we
can just
go live on our platforms and nadeem goes
this is too much joy to not share
it's perfect
as you wish of course as you wish
i like i like that the meditation the
abiding
the communication the reflections
[Music]
all happen and that's why the al
chemistry
of the container and the retreat
continues to gravitate us towards one
another like right now
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we can uh invite those that are
in this chat space watching
our communication this meditation
i'd love to invite you when there is
moments of silence see if you can just
let go of the need to describe
to follow the descriptions and just also
give yourself a few moments
pressure fresh grease
no activity nothing to be
just resting in the mystery
um
[Music]
[Music]
another thing to see is that from this
space the thing that
makes this speaking is relevance
rather than anything
now like when there is just this
silence is already wholeness
it's completion and the thing that makes
you speak from there is relevance
the relevance to communicate something
rather than the need by yourself to
communicate something
it was powerful to see distinction
there's no longer a lack there's no
longer a need
rather there's a spontaneous
creativity and
pure joyful peaceful illuminative
relevance
i got that reflected to me at
the retreat
by corey
she was
telling me about how
for us to hang out and talk
to
make it less about the need
and rather more about the spontaneous
intentional playful creativity
relevance
listen to me because i need to share
with you
my experience because i need you to
validate
me huge difference
[Music]
huge difference
huh it's like it's like
it's like the hummingbird coming over to
the flower for nectar
okay did you did you hear my bit you
know okay it's like the hummingbird did
you hear me say that part
yeah yeah it's like it's like the
hummingbird
coming over to the flower for nectar
and just coming over to the flower for
nectar and like before it goes to the
flower for nectar
it like looks around and it's like are
there other people
watching me as i enjoy this nectar
because if there aren't other people
watching me i'm not going to enjoy the
sector
we're just a simple bird the simple bird
that's perched up on the branch if it's
not sending over
communications about
food and where food is or about there
being
potentially another animal trying to
prey on the birds and sending warning
signals
that we speak a lot about
the bird's song just singing
just singing without
an audience
just singing
express yourself
don't express yourself
what's the difference if there's nobody
watching or if there's one person
watching
or 100 people watching express
yourself just that in itself
feeling whole feeling like you
are intelligent infinity endlessly
expressing itself as all of the creative
possibilities
and that this nadeem and atlas
costume is beautiful
and that it's its own creative unique
firework and gift and expression into
this dream
creation but in order for
it to express itself as
god's love light it has to be done
from a place of knowing its true
nature you have to know your true
nature in order for your firework
to express itself from a place of
wholeness from a place of perfection
from a place of completion not from a
place of lack
not from a place of needing not from a
place of trying to
take maya take
peace and happiness from maya
mm-hmm yeah i i loved for
i think one of your previous videos you
uh that's something about
but there being less pulse note played
but you can't now the firework the
expression of the firework
there will be less false note
therefore
like the symphonic
aspect to intelligent infinity
is that you have this range of more
icy egoic separate
finite contracted attached to form and
identity
attached to their personhood
and that can be thought of as out of
tune
in the symphony of course in the
non-dual understanding everything's
already perfect and in tune but then in
the dualistic concession that we hold
simultaneously
that there is also a
out of tune because there's trying to
seek peace and happiness from substances
and experiences and other people
in relationships and i will only be
happy
when i have my nice watch that i can
show off to people
and so that's the archetype and that's
what
hits the wall when the parable of the
prodigal son
and then turns inward towards
awareness itself and
those that play in tune in the symphony
are those that know that the nature of
their
impersonal eternal awareness itself is
peace and joy and illumination it
is the sunlight itself
karma yoga the sun never ever
expects to sit in the shade it never
expects to eat
the fruits of the tree it just gives
it just waters it just delivers
nourishment endlessly but balanced with
wisdom
again for us into the unity
because the graceful loving
kind
that we create for ourselves
rather than the martyrdom is mission
critical
as well yes
the symphony is a good one i'm glad you
wrote that that's a good idea
it's like it sounds like this and i did
this in the
simulation 740 episode with hillary and
gina and gilad that it sounds
like this when you're in the more
enlightened symphonic
vibration it sounds like
[Music]
and then when you're in the egoic
out of tune vibration it sounds like
i liked it
i feel like we're getting to a pretty
good place to also rap soon
[Music]
that was really strong
ah
as nadeem said take this moment
where both of us are just relaxed
into being
and use it yourself
also stop
describing your experience stop
with the symbolization and just
relax into the very
fact of existing
i am
just relax into awareness without
description
and just stay there for a bit with us
and if it comes up to giggle like a kid
giggle if you feel joy
abide in that
that's the satchada
and it's great to do that for a minute
and more but for those that are really
beginners just do it for
two to five seconds
it's that gym repetition
aren't you aren't you interested when
you look at these yogis and mystics that
have
united truly through this veilless veil
this gateless gate with their true
nature
and have abided and refined and purified
themselves into just
the absolute gods love light don't you
wonder
don't you have interest don't you have
desire
to know
that well the infinite well
of honey the waterfall of bliss
and joy and peace and ecstasy
from just the very fact
that they are
don't you have interest
how is it that they are
that incredible bliss
peace illumination
and why am i a mixed bag of frequencies
the mind toiling me around taking me
around i must
enter into the matrix machine and earn
money and get a 30-year mortgage and oh
my god
how do i happy how do i happy i don't
know how happy uh
look at the difference there's a big
difference
and so ask yourself the question why
how do these yogis do these mystics
through these people that know their
true nature
feel bliss joy peace
illumination ecstasy just
from pure being
itself
nadeem's in france right now
and oh it's a little later
his time nadeem has been posting some
good
content on his instagram we'll put the
link in the bio below for you to
go and give him a follow and check that
out and
nadeem are you going to start a youtube
channel uh
yes i was inspired
i think one of these days i'll open the
channel
the little picture and i start sharing
the content there
yeah you already have a lot of video
content of you talking on
instagram that you can also just port
and upload over to youtube as well
and then everything most of it now is
is on facebook like i didn't chat much
faster
and so now i'm starting yeah again
from more purified space
so i feel a lot of inspiration and
openness
to share so there will come more content
in the following days and weeks
to come this is the intention i will
open the youtube channel and we will add
it here too
and then whatever is the platform
the people for the most
the easiest place to get organic reach
right now is youtube
and the second best place to get organic
reach is tick tock
and then the third best organic place to
get reach
is instagram reels so
reels yeah but reels have to be under
30 or so seconds but
the best place to get reach is still
tick tock but then those are really
short
videos and so to get
reach with longer videos the best place
right now is youtube
yep yeah i'm on tiktok as well
like the inspiration that came was uh
because of the group that is forming
through the costa
rica retreat maybe we can make a shared
tick tock
and we can take uh the highlights of
everyone's
shared content hmm
kind of like uh kitchen we can see
what i've read one of it stays
true what stays exciting but it can can
be an option
i'm just not so familiar with youtube
but through the the way that you
open this channel and the communication
and the shared live videos and
everything it's really nice
feels really good very spontaneous
so yeah good inspirations bro
yeah it was right four years of
doing this type of stuff and then over
time it just
becomes streamlined right and easy
so we it's still
early right 2021 is still early
in the media game
and so to get into
the different social platforms as a
enlightenment or
awakening media focused
brand is really mission critical to
going from that yellow third density
matrix to the fourth density
heart chakra love because that's really
the transition requires us to take
more of the collective consciousness and
move it towards enlightenment and
awakening media and away from the matrix
propaganda of our own creation
we created the matrix propaganda
ourselves
to liberate ourselves from our own
creation
and another piece that is important to
say is that
when you look at
the mystics when you look at the yogis
that have communed with their true
nature that feel
that infinite waterfall
well of honey ecstasy bliss
peace illumination
they don't require
money a lot of people
are stuck thinking
that i need money
in order for me to feel
bliss peace
illumination
if you have the simple
water
the simple bit of food
there are plenty of examples of people
with just that
that feel that
ecstasy of just pure being itself
now having shelter
having electricity having
computers
are also
solid additions
that are very double-edged in many ways
the same way you can have a shelter
that you have
just a little mattress pad
to lay on is the same double-edged
shelter that can be a 30-year mortgage
the same computer that you have
can be used for enlightenment media
that can be used to completely
utterly distract yourself with the
biggest
matrix propaganda
so know that and the same thing with
food even food
can be used for the bits
of nourishment or it can be
used to fulfill
a distorted kink in your existence
which is the addiction to the
neurochemical storm that you get from
salt oil and sugar and high fructose
corn syrup
so he said just have that vigilance
you know what know that
the yogis the mystics
the satchitananda itself
does not have prerequisites
what this prerequisites mean
it does not have
attributes that you need to have
in order to feel satchitananda
you don't need something first to
feel satcha not
although again
this nuanced simultaneity
that having clean water
and having the bit of food
facilitates the ease
yes because now in the demon i don't
have to go
and find a spring to get water
yeah and so it's just easier for us to
relax
because we have that filtered water on
tap
rather than needing to also have a
spring
so yeah
be powerful from time to time come back
to that wonder
of how easy we have it in certain ways
yeah because it's easy to lose the
wonder of creation when we grow up with
a certain
part it's like it's always been there
for everyone not all the time everyone
but still for most of those that listen
that is you
there is a certain level of comfort
all readiness of all the things that
needs for survival for these things
it's really powerful to then see how
yeah how raw the creation actually is
you know like a few hundred years ago if
you would live it would feel
completely different
there would be more
more opportunities to instantly die
and now for example it's like just
closer to that
and i feel one of the things that we can
do because we don't have to give
everything away
by saying although we can do that or
with a part of it or whatever is
powerful
which we can just imagine use the power
of the imagination
that we are going to die physically
the her body is going this
this dream this dream
with the character and this stay out of
play
how it is playing out it is going to end
and the more that i remind myself of
that
or become aware of that and really tune
in
um the more you come to life right it's
a funny thing
becoming aware that your body is going
to die someday
makes you come more alive makes you
more careless about things you should
not care about
about silly things
right about
all the things that are ruining our
or maybe to start in the retreat section
i have recently i see like
imagine a few hundred thousand years
from now
nobody is going to know your name nobody
is going to remember it
and now you think it's so important what
you say
trying not to fail no no no no no
but it's gonna fly away like this
like nothing and when we
when we play with that imagination with
the truth you just tune into that
and and the mind can be a little bit
afraid of that because it thinks it will
become
careless in the sense of like not caring
about anything and
being nonchalant of these things but the
funny thing is that the non-caring and
the non-challenge
comes from the fear comes from the being
bound
comes from the caring about so many
things and it being too much
but if these things resolve through
whatever reason within this moment
through that imagination of meetings the
end of this lifetime
and point this storyline
narrative then
it's okay
and in that in its freedom in that
happiness there is the autumn
uh automatic uh response i would say
towards true care
or whatever appears whatever you are
present to whatever
circumstance your family your friends
there is this
natural care and in the same time you
don't need them to change
anymore you don't expect from them
anything else than that what they want
but they when they ask you vibrationally
in speech
and know like
then um really effective like the one
natural is
how effective it is
yeah now i saw so many times that
someone was paying and i was
wanting or helping being to be in pain
only because it confronted me with when
i was in pain and i didn't want it to
feel that
something like this you know and then
you dress that up as yeah i'm just
wanting to help you and uh
these things it's just because i don't
want to bear with discomfort of that
moment
and it's just one of many of the things
by everything so sorry within myself
to then really allow being to feel
whatever it is feeling
because it is its own guiding like it is
its own catalyst
and uh yeah there is a lot of nuance and
maturity that happens in that
that involvement maybe just a nice
example of the many many things that
the size of the game of purification
genuinification of the service
so yeah
nadine brings up a very important point
relax into
the very fact
that this play
happening right now
is beautiful and perfect
and free
and a hundred thousand years from now
nobody will give a [ __ ] about this play
uh
yeah i saw a few months ago i saw
a session on youtube of someone
that is kind of the
leader or manager of a group of people
who are working
on technology that is most probably
going to come out some
extra personal technologies that have
been shared
and some of these things are like
for me either if they they come fast but
it's just like what it opened what it
opens for me
for example the way that communication
is going to happen is going to shift
completely
like internet is going to disappear and
the communication will be through a
device that is
the size of a coin and you can just put
it and i can say car atlas
and then this
beam is projected out of the coin and
you can have
the silhouette of atlas
and communicate like this and that
will be in your brain
it won't be it won't be outside of you
anymore
i think the mind is in between phase
it's in between phase
yeah yeah but but the internet won't
disappear
no no the internet stays
because that's the fabric that we use
through which we communicate even when
we get to the place of
the telepathic that it's still a
internet that enables us to
do that process it's it's always been an
internet
it's like the oxygen that i inhale right
now
comes from the phytoplankton in trees
that's an
internet it's an interweb of
interdependent
relationship yeah yeah it's maybe just
the
the screen that disappears like the way
we see internet like google maybe just
the idea of like taking a screen typing
in google and
finding things like that that i had that
i have this
external device that that
that changes because it's no longer an
external device
as you say the next phase brings it down
even more in size creates these
holographic style projections is voice
activated
and then eventually even that external
device becomes
internal and that and so we're we're
talking like
50 100 years we're talking like
we're here not speaking 50 years he was
speaking
like six years 10 years
but not for all the technologies but
yeah i think
for the major shifts will be some
decades
for sure um but there was something else
maybe just to bring in because it opened
the infinite abundance
it was really cool permission slip uh
was there replicators
the star trek replicator this very very
important technology for abundance yeah
yeah it can like one of the examples is
for example if you want
a certain meal you can just
type in the rest the recipe and just out
of the eater out of the
like i don't know how to use this e
equals m c
squared it uses the mass energy
equivalence because it turns it from
pure energy
into the specific recipe that you've
indicated yeah exactly that so the
the quest is like if they make a
replicator big enough to replicate
replicators
and then the whole planet can have
replicators
very fast and then uh
you you you will have automatically
uh all the food that you need you know
that can there will be no starvation no
of these
viable things anymore and this will just
there are many of these technologies
right
it just feels like um
yeah like it will be this next level
permissions
global to lucidify the consciousness
perfect into infinite everythingness
and infinite abundance being represented
through these technologies
as an intermediate step to tap into that
again
you know because it's
it's like growing up on this planet you
really start to believe that there is
not enough of everything for everyone on
the planet
when you grow up you know it's like
crazy
this was just a powerful permission slip
for me to to
like connect to that infinity
becoming also physicalized
representative
quite soon i love that i love that such
a good way to put it that
this star trek style
future technologies
and this is where science and
engineering
and technology are really important
that the anchoring of those technologies
into our decentralized social fabric
are also creating the permission slips
as nadeem said
for us to more
frictionlessly commune with our true
nature as
intelligent infinity
and the vitality of the different bodies
will go
up so much like there will be so much of
the light body
easily activated for mass consciousness
you can see
yeah so it's gonna open new games and
it's gonna
like i perceive at least the parallel
version of this planet i'm shifting into
uh or that i'm playing with the
imagination of to raise the vibration
through that choice um it will open for
new ways of exploration that we have no
access to yet
with that this the base ground
that everyone has food that the body is
fully generally
generated again because they have this
machines these tubes where you can go
laying
and it reanimates the body in in two and
a half minutes
for example you lost your leg through
the
coat in the dna they can just reanimate
that leg in 2.5 minutes
it's crazy
and then ride an exoskeleton itself
yes and then ride a
complete formlessness which you which
you already are
but even more so liberated from
the physical even more so liberated from
the physical
into something that's like a it's like a
disney world
for consciousness it's gonna be so
[Music]
it's also been called the metaverse
yeah that collective lucidity
of the disney world of consciousness
has been called the metaverse where
you basically can
right now
will into
an infinite amount of
designer realities
and just enter in
one day one year 100 years
three seconds however long you want
just like a game where you take the
controller
and you play and you play and then you
pause switch to a different game
and you can do that seamlessly
frictionlessly like disney world of
consciousness
metaverse collective lucidity
also with just even this right here
we we get a really good amount of data
of joy
and peace and illumination just being
here together
but there's even more data
and direct experience
of satchitananda to still even be able
to
feel even more
of that infinite waterfall of ecstasy
that's already our perfect nature
infinitely more yeah
yep infinitely more
okay let's wrap
a good way to to wrap the nature
is both absolute
void and also absolute
infinitely more
[Music]
yes thank you i very much enjoyed
excited we'll do more of these as they
blossom spontaneously
i look forward to them you're so
exciting you're so special
adore you infinitely yeah and maybe in
the future we can
bring the color of my twin brother in
the mix
i would love that really nice that would
be a nice
[Music]
i feel a really nice dynamic uh
consensus of the three of us
uh three instruments matching us one
express that's what is infinity
i'd love that and also the
other highly realized
members from the retreat also so that
would be fun to do
we'll do that what's your what's your
brother's name again
yes yes yes cool
it's cool all right
connect with uh in this way with the
rest of the group
yeah it feels a very natural unfoldment
it's really good yeah
and like and like you said
before we started that
this joy is so
yummy we can't not share it we have to
share it
yeah he
[Music]
yeah i love it
all right thanks everyone for tuning in
we love you we adore you infinitely
thank you
give the video a like helps the
algorithm subscribe if you haven't yet
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you
wherever you're at on your
realization on your abiding
and share the video with people that you
feel like
this would positively resonate with
check out the links in the bio below to
nd
and that is
all
we can do a little singy sing sing song
nadeem and i have been sending each
other some songy voices
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
[Laughter]
pop
da
[Music]
one
so cute i love that
so cute bro
oh i love it oh
okay that's a wrap all right i'll end
the
broadcast we'll stick around in the
studio and talk here
all right thanks everyone bye-bye
bye bye